That's like
crazy. The breath. How was me seeing
a headline of them on deadline?
I know they have a new show. I know
that it's good for all of us, but like
new show and it's in the
slot that your show was in.
You know what it is.
I literally have to unfollow girls
sometimes who I'm friends with who are in,
who are comedians, who are my peers and
who I respect and think they're funny.
I have to unfollow them if I
see that they're just like,
I'm working a lot right now and they're
putting out there that they're like
really busy with work and I just got
kicked off dancing with the stars.
I have to unfollow them because?
Because I start to feel sad about myself
and I would rather just remove that
from my feed then and then it's a really
awkward follow when I know or they
messaged me on one of those things and
they see I'm not following them because
it's like we all know we
follow each other. Right.
They know and sometimes I'll just tell
them, I'm unfollowed you because you,
you make me feel sad about my own career.
I'm not going to get over that.
It's easier to just take them out of
my feed. Yeah, but that's a weird one.
I am working to get over it that I am
just, just use it as infor
like his inspiration. Use
them as fuel to work harder.
Yeah,
I do.
But I would also like to not see
their toward eight schedule all crazy.
It got crazy. That one go.
That's not a good one to accept.
I don't think. You know what? I probably,
I'm probably going to unfollow
one a all all you guys with your,
with your workouts and your calorie
counts that you've posted them a couple
times but I didn't even post the big one.
I didn't literally growing as
fuck to people who, who are like,
Eh, you know, hate their bodies and
stuff. Yeah. It can be very triggering.
So like girls, they're like, I just ran
a marathon. I'm like, unfollow. I can't,
I can't have you in my life
bragging about the shit. Listen,
I go to the gym too and I don't tweet
about it. I want to, Goddamn, I want to,
I just heard so many calories,
but I don't tweet tweet about it because
I don't want to trigger people and I
don't want to be the, I don't want
to be what I am so jealous of,
but I should brag about it.
And I also like that some people are like,
look at what I just did it the gym.
Fuck you.
I'd worked today and they're proud of
themselves, but I can't, I can't see.
I get inspired.
Okay.
Do you know who I go to like all the
time for inspiration? The Rock? Yeah.
That motherfucker never
stops. He never stops. I mean,
I don't want to do what he's doing.
I don't want to do these movies.
I don't want to do what he's doing,
but that I fucking admire the shit out
of that guy's work ethic. That guy,
I'll fly to Tokyo,
it will be four o'clock in the morning.
He sets up an elliptical machine, starts
going after it. That's what he does.
And that doesn't make, that doesn't put
you in a place of like, I'm, I'm never,
I can't, no, no, because you can, but
the thing is, Joe Rogan, you can do that.
Look at that. Look at all his food and
he gets to do that because you said,
Oh God,
he landed in London, midnight ordered
Sushi like a motherfucker. Go to his, uh,
his Instagram with all the workout
ones. This is, you are the Rock Joe.
You are the rock.
You do these workouts all the time.
That's how you get that
shirt.
That's what I'm saying.
Rock.
I got a text today from David Goggins
and I told David Goggins I'm trying to
beat everyone by double. He's
like, fuck yeah, kill it.
Like capital a hundred exclamation points.
That's what I'm saying. Look at
that dude focused. I see that.
I want to go work out right now.